it's time to talk parenting trends and
understanding kids as i
mom explain it all does your kid talk a
lot
they could be one of our future leaders
according to new research in the
leadership
quarterly those who spend more time
talking tend to emerge as the leaders
of initially leaderless groups it's
called
the babel hypothesis and it seems to
occur regardless of someone's
intelligence or their personality traits
researchers say that when someone speaks
it gives a perception that that person
has leadership qualities this could also
be why teachers make their students
speak up in class
the more a person speaks in a group the
more likely they were viewed as
the leader of the group kids seem always
to also have a superpower
for finding all the goodies that you've
stashed in the back of the cupboard so
oreo is helping you take things to the
next level they just announced a new
protection program which is designed to
hide oreo fins from your family
using camouflaged packaging
our kids keep stealing our oreo fins so
we got this camouflage pack to keep them
safe
it's our oreo thins that's kevin jonas
and they say that oreo fins
are there for them and they have the
label on the front but the sides look
different so you can stack them wherever
you'd want to hide them the cupboard the
freezer the closet or in the car
now the spines make the oreos look like
a cookbook or a package of frozen
vegetables or a pack of t-shirts
a car owner's manual but for now they're
only available
through an online sweepstakes that
deadline is on friday
and finally dictionary.com has added
some new slang that you may want to stay
up to date on
some of the new words include yeet which
is an
exclamation of enthusiasm triumph
pleasure or
it means to hurl or remove something
forcefully
5g the new faster system for
transferring data especially to cell
phones
you have long coved the condition in
which health problems remain or surface
after the patient is thought to have
recovered from the illness
zaddy that is a man who if not the whole
package is at least very attractive
stylish charming and confident
and oof an exclamation of empathy or
of the speaker's own pain sort of a
counter to ye
oh i think i've run out of time i guess
i better yeet on out of here and
now you've had a mom's plating jc